[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedryserien schönen guten Abend
Basketball WM und Leichtathletik hat
später Kristin im Sport nein ein
bisschen Volleyball guten Abend dann
blicken wir jetzt gemeinsam auf die
Themen an diesem Montag
Grundsicherung für Kinder lange hoch
umstritten sind die Eckpunkte seit heute
klar wichtige Details müssen aber noch
besprochen werden
die EVG sagt ja zum schlichter Spruch
damit sind unbefristete Streiks bei der
Bahn vom Tisch
in Bayern wird in den unwetterregionen
aufgeräumt aber es schüttet weiter
praktisch überall in den Alpen
rechtzeitig vor der morgen beginnenden
Kabinettsklausur wurde der Streit über
die sogenannte Kindergrundsicherung
beigelegt Monate langstritten
Familienministerin und Finanzminister
vor allem übers Geld und präsentierten
heute Einigung und Entwurf dazu gleich
mehr zuvor zeigt Andrea Maurer was sich
mit der Reform ändern soll
die Kinder Grundsicherung bündelt alle
Finanzhilfen für Kinder von Kindergeld
über Kinderfreibetrag Kinderzuschlag bis
hin zu Sozialleistungen in Zukunft soll
es einen festen kindergarantiebetrag für
alle Kinder geben unabhängig vom
Einkommen der Eltern zunächst in Höhe
des heutigen Kindergeldes also 250 € im
Monat Eltern beantragen den
garantiebetrag online nach der Geburt
und geben mir Einverständnis das Daten
abgeglichen werden das Kind erhält dann
automatisch den garantiebetrag und je
nachdem was die Eltern verdienen auch
einen flexiblen kinderzusatzbetrag je
niedriger das Einkommen der Eltern desto
höher die Leistung geplant ist dass hier
unter anderem das bisherige Kinder
Bürgergeld aufgenommen wird auch der
Kinderzuschlag für Familien mit geringem
Einkommen soll darin aufgehen
bei Alleinerziehenden soll die
Unterhaltszahlung als Einkommen künftig
nur noch zu 45% in die Berechnung der
Sozialleistungen einfließen nicht mehr
wie bisher zu 100%
. ja Familienministerin Paul von den
Grünen hat Hochgepokert nicht so viel
bekommen zeigt sich aber dennoch
zufrieden Christian Lindner sieht auch
ein gutes Ergebnis prophezeit aber wegen
der angespannten Haushaltslage das ist
wohl für lange Zeit die letzte große
Sozialreform bleibt Heikes lanski über
Kritik Einigung und Frage Fragezeichen
als wäre nichts gewesen treten am
Vormittag zufriedene ampelminister vor
die Hauptstadtpresse tatsächlich hatten
sie noch bis kurz vor Mitternacht
gerungen nun der Durchbruch bis zu 5,6
Millionen armutsbedrohte Familien und
ihre Kinder bekommen dadurch die
Leistungen schneller einfacher und
direkter Millionen darunter die vorher
gar nicht wussten dass Ihnen diese
Unterstützung zusteht
Hochgepokert hatte die grüne
Familienministerin ursprünglich forderte
sie zwölf Milliarden herausgekommen sind
2,4 der liberale Finanzminister hat sich
durchgesetzt betont des gelbe keine
generellen Leistungserhöhungen das beste
Umarmung zu überwinden ist Arbeit
denn der Grund für kinderarmut ist ja
oft die
Armut an Arbeit an Integration an
Sprachkenntnissen der Eltern
unzureichend sei das Ergebnis
kritisieren Sozialverbände das einst
ambitionierte Vorhaben geschrumpft auf
eine Verwaltungsreform
das ist nicht der große Wurf der
Paradigmenwechsel sondern es sind
leichte Verbesserungen für eine
Kindergrundsicherung muss mehr kommen
die Union nicht von einer Mogelpackung
warnt vor noch mehr Bürokratie wir
fordern tatsächliche Verbesserungen für
Kinder Unterstützung Familien von Beginn
an über ein gutes gutes frühkindliches
Bildungssystem das wichtigste
sozialpolitische Projekt der Ampel geht
nun in die nächste Runde
Expertenanhörungen
Bundestagsdebatten Ausgang offen
er die in Berlin 12 Milliarden Euro
hatte Familienminister und Pauls
veranschlagt das sind ja dann wirklich
deutlich weniger geworden und trotzdem
gibt sich Post zufrieden wie passt das
zusammen
ich habe hier leichte Tonprobleme aber
soweit ich das verstanden habe geht es
um die Zufriedenheit und ich muss sagen
die etwas anderes als politische Problem
politische Zufriedenheit wäre Frau Paus
heute gar nicht anders gar nicht übrig
geblieben denn die Ampel musste heute
beweisen dass sie noch etwas anderes
kann als Dauerstreit und Lisa Pause
heute glaubhaft machen dass der kracht
den sie damit verursacht hat sich auch
gelohnt hat und deswegen dürfte sie
heute auch zwei Punkte besonders betont
haben zum einmal dass die gestrige
Entscheidung einen Paradigmenwechsel bei
der Kindergrundsicherung mit sich
gebracht hat und auch dass die 2,4
Milliarden für 20 25 eben nur ein
Startgeld sozusagen sind und dass es in
den Jahren darauf deutlich ansteigen
könnte bis zu 6 Milliarden nimmt sie an
im Jahr 2028 wenn deutlich mehr Familien
auf das Geld zugreifen können ähm dass
die Zufriedenheit allerdings nicht
wirklich von Herzen kamen das konnte man
dann einer Aussage merken da sagte sie
nämlich zum Schluss ihres Eingangsdaten
mit angesichts der Haushaltslage und der
sich einen trüben den wirtschaftlichen
Situationen des Bundes sei sie zufrieden
übersetzt heißt das es war einfach nicht
mehr drin ohne die Unterstützung von
Olaf Scholz gegen Christian Lindner
vielen Dank für die Einordnung und auch
die Kollegen von wieso greifen das Thema
Kindergrundsicherung auf gleich im
Anschluss an unsere Sendung
angesichts der schwächelnden Konjunktur
fordert die Wirtschaft von der Regierung
mehr Hilfen unter anderem einen
günstigeren Strompreis jetzt hat sich
die SPD-Bundestagsfraktion bei ihrem
Treffen in Wiesbaden auf einen
subventionierten industriestrompreis von
ca 5 Cent pro Kilowattstunde für
energieintensive Unternehmen geeinigt
zunächst auf 5 Jahre befristet Kanzler
Scholz war bislang skeptisch die Grünen
schlagen 6 Cent vor die FDP lehnt diese
Staatshilfe ab
der Zugreisende können aufatmen
unbefristete Streiks bei der Deutschen
Bahn die sind erstmal vom Tisch die
Mitglieder der Eisenbahner Gewerkschaft
EVG haben sich mehrheitlich dafür
ausgesprochen das Ergebnis der
Schlichtung anzunehmen für die 180.000
Beschäftigten bedeutet das sie erhalten
in zwei Schritten einen Festbetrag von
410 € monatlich und eine steuerfreie
Einmalzahlung von 2850 Euro dazu kommen
dann noch Sonderregelung für bestimmte
Berufsgruppen für die Bahn ist es die
teuerste tarifanhebung in der Geschichte
Hans-jürgen Piel
zweimal hatte die EVG den
Schienenverkehr deutschlandweit
lahmgelegt seit Februar ergebnislos
verhandelt erst ein Kompromissvorschlag
der Schlichter Thomas de Maizière und
Heide Pfarr konnte den Tarifstreit
beenden gut 52% der Stimmberechtigten
evg-mitgliedersprachen sich jetzt für
dessen Annahme aus damit haben wir einen
solidarischen Tarifabschluss der vor
allem den kleineren und mittleren
Einkommen ein deutliches Plus bringt 410
Euro plus sollen künftig alle Bahn
Mitarbeiter bekommen einige bisher
benachteiligte Berufsgruppen aber
besonders begünstigt werden
Fahrdienstleiter etwa halten bis zu 900
€ mehr Zugbegleiter 840 und Werkstatt
Mitarbeiter bis zu 860 € Gehaltserhöhung
das hatte bereits für Grummeln bei
Kollegen gesorgt die nur die allgemeine
Erhöhung gehalten sollen für die
Deutsche Bahn wird der Tarifabschluss
teuer schriftlich teilte
Personalvorstand Seiler heute mit mit
diesem Abschluss erkennen wir die
Leistung unserer Mitarbeitenden an auch
wenn er uns wirtschaftlich sehr viel
abverlangt für beim Kunden bedeutet der
Abschluss jetzt zumindest zwei Monate
ohne Streit Gefahren ab November
beginnen neue Tarifverhandlungen dann
mit der Lokführergewerkschaft
sechs Wochen vor der Landtagswahl in
Bayern hat Ministerpräsident Söder für
morgen eine Sondersitzung des
Koalitionsausschusses einberufen sein
Stellvertreter und Koalitionspartner
freie wählerchef aanger soll sich
persönlich erklären hintergrund ist ein
antisemitisches Flugblatt aus
Schulzeiten eiwanger hatte eingeräumt
dass ein oder weniger Exemplare des
Blattes damals in seiner Schultasche
gefunden worden waren kurz darauf
gestand sein Bruder der Verfasser zu
sein und auch Kanzler Scholz drängt
inzwischen auf weitere Aufklärung jetzt
in die Ukraine dort Rücken ukrainische
Streitkräfte nach eigenen Angaben weiter
vor jeder Quadratkilometer der
zurückerobert wird zählt als Sieg aber
der Krieg hinterlässt tiefe Spuren die
Ukraine früher Teil der Sowjetunion
teilte mit Russland Sprache und Kultur
jetzt suchen oder betonen viele Menschen
die eigene ukrainische Identität aus
Rake
früher war das mal die Moskauer Straße
jetzt heißt sie Helden von rakev die
Stadt hat schon 50 Straßen umbenannt
insgesamt sollen es 500 werden
wir schreiben unsere Geschichte nicht um
wir gewinnen unsere Geschichte zurück
die auf die eine oder andere Weise
vernichtet wurde durch den sowjetischen
Propagandaapparat durch das Imperium das
uns seine narrative aufzwang
fliegt nahe der Grenze zu Russland zu
Beginn des Kriegs wurde die Stadt massiv
angegriffen bis heute gibt es hier
täglich Luftalarm schlagen russische
Raketen ein
sagen Sie was Sie wollen aber Russland
hat unsere Stadt zerstört und niemand
anders leider
russisch Ukrainisch in harkev existiert
nach wie vor beides nebeneinander viele
sprechen zu Hause russisch ein
Überbleibsel auf sowjetszeiten jetzt
gibt es hier Ukrainisch Kurse
das ist meine Muttersprache und ich will
meine Kenntnisse darin vertiefen die
Ukraine auf der Suche nach der eigenen
Identität Denkmäler sind zum Schutz
eingehüllt auch das für Alexander
Puschkin den russischen nationaltichter
seine Statue wurde inzwischen entfernt
ich war von Anfang an nicht mit allem
einverstanden weil es Namen gibt die
wieder zu Russland noch zur Ukraine
gehörten
in erschaffen sie Neues aus den Resten
von russischen Raketen haben Sie hier
einfach Kunst gemacht
im Schatten des Ukraine Krieges schwebt
ein anderer Konflikt weiter im Kaukasus
es geht um Bergkarabach dort wächst die
Verzweiflung es herrscht Hunger das
Gebiet wird mehrheitlich von Armenien
bewohnt wird aber vom umliegenden
Aserbaidschan beansprucht der sogenannte
login-korridor ist die versorgungsader
für mehr als 100.000 Menschen aber der
wird seit Ende letzten Jahres von der
Regierung in Baku blockiert Nahrung und
Medikamente kommen nicht durch Nina
Niebergall
das Elend hat in Bergkarabach eine
Nummer sie bestimmt über den Platz in
der Warteschlange wer hungern muss und
wer ausnahmsweise genug zu essen bekommt
ich habe vier Kinder von denen drei
Soldaten sind von morgens bis abends
stehe ich in der Schlange damit sie
etwas zu Mittagessen bekommen
es leiden vor allem die schwächsten
Kinder Schwangere ein Mann sondern
Unterernährung gestorben sein der
Vorwurf der Berg Karabach Arminia
Aserbaidschan wolle sie aushungern
seit Dezember blockiert Aserbaidschan
den Zugang von Armenien nach
Bergkarabach lies nur noch solche
Hilfstransporte durch seit kurzem auch
die nicht mehr
gehham asroyan hat seine Zahnarztpraxis
immerhin noch geöffnet viele Kliniken
sind schon geschlossen
wegen der Blockade haben wir einen sehr
ernsten Mangel an Medikamenten
die Lösung die Aserbaidschan anbietet
will gerham als früher auf keinen Fall
die lautet bei Karabach sondern
Aserbaidschan integriert werden dann sei
die Versorgung wieder sicher
ich sehe nur eine Option für die wir
kämpfen und dann die ich mich noch aus
meiner Kindheit erinnere die Vereinigung
von arzach und Armenien
die Armenia Bergkarabach das
Aserbaidschan Sie hier in Frieden leben
lässt daran glaubt kaum jemand
[Musik]
heute vor 35 Jahren geschah etwas das
als größte flugschaukatastrophe in die
deutsche Geschichte einging das Unglück
im rheinland-pfälzischen Ramstein
100 tausende Besucher viele Familien mit
Kindern auf dem US-Stützpunkt nahe
Kaiserslautern sie bestaunen
italienische kunstfliege als plötzlich
drei Maschinen zusammenstoßen eine Rast
brennend ins Publikum explodiert 70
Menschen sterben in den Flammen etwa
1000 werden verletzt viele davon schwer
über die Folgen von Rammstein Marion
Geiger
sie treffen sich jedes Jahr in Ramstein
um sich gemeinsam zu erinnern um 15 Uhr
halten sie inne in dieser minute kam es
vor 35 Jahren zur Katastrophe
auf der US Airbase ist Flugtag doch ein
Manöver misslingt
Mark David jung war damals vier Jahre
alt und mit seinen Eltern dort seine
Mutter konnte ihn schwer verletzt aus
dem Trümmern ziehen sein Vater hat nicht
überlebt den Tag der Katastrophe
vergisst er nie
Tag des Erinnerns verteilt das Revue
passierens
ein Tag um auch in die Zukunft zu
schauen und zu danken dass ich auch am
Leben bin
Marliese und Alfred Witt verlorenen
Rammstein ihren Sohn Mario war 16 und
galt sechs Tage lang als vermisst man
ist in einem Wechselbad der Gefühle weil
es einfach man hat immer noch Hoffnung
in einer Minute und eine Minute später
schon wieder eine kann doch nicht sein
das absolut unnormalste ist eben dass
ich ein Kind verliere
das ist das schlimmste was ich mir nicht
nur für mich auch für andere
vorstellen kann
die Katastrophe von Rammstein viele
Betroffene begleitet sie ihr Leben lang
auffüllende Bilder und Aussagen
im Süden von Bayern hat eine
Gewitterfront am Wochenende massive
Schäden angerichtet besonders schwer
traf es den Ort Bad Bayersoien dort
wurde der Katastrophenfall ausgerufen
ein groß angelegter hilfsansatz läuft
unzählige Dächer müssen gesichert werden
weil riesige Hagelkörner sie einfach
durchschlagen haben Petra Neubauer
berichtet
was da am Wochenende in Südbayern
herunter prasselt ist verheerend
Hagelkörner mit einem Durchmesser von
rund 8 cm hinterlassen in Bad Bayersoien
im Landkreis Garmisch-Partenkirchen
Chaos und Zerstörung das war eine so
eine Gewalt dass man schon wenn es so
weitergeht dann stehen wir in unserem
Wohnzimmer neu im Wasser drin 80% der
Gebäude sind schwer beschädigt nun
werden sie notdürftig mit Planen gegen
den eindringenden Regen abgedichtet der
Landrat spricht von einem Inferno und
ruft den Katastrophenfall aus umso mehr
Helfer anfordern zu können wenn man den
kaufverlauf bekommt man über
örtliche Einsatzkräfte über örtliches
Material und es war notwendig wenn man
sie vorstellt 300 € Häuser müssen
abgedeckt werden 300 Häuser und das Dach
komplett zerstörtisch die neue
Bundesstraße 23 wird kurzzeitig gesperrt
der Hagel hat hier zu viele Autos
beschädigt eine Weiterfahrt
unmöglich etwas weiter östlich hat es
auch das historische Kloster
Benediktbeuren getroffen durch die
zerstörten und eingedrückten Fenster
läuft Wasser ins Gebäude das Gebälk
quillt auf der Schaden geht in die
Millionen
Südbayern erlebt ein unwetterwochenende
mit gewaltigen folgen sie alle zu
beseitigen wird Wochen wenn nicht Monate
dauern
und nicht nur in Bayern kämpfen die
Menschen mit den Wassermassen auch in
Österreich ist die Situation wegen des
Starkregens angespannt in Tirol
erreichen die Flüsse Pegelstände wie
seit Jahrzehnten nicht mehr zahlreiche
Straßen wurden überschwemmt besonders
schlimm ist es im Ötztal dort haben die
Wassermassen eine Bundesstraße
weggerissen so dass einige Gemeinden
nicht mehr erreichbar sind
wir machen jetzt sportlich weiter keine
Medaillen für die deutschen bei der
Leichtathletik Weltmeisterschaft im
budapest ist schon bitter aggressiv
ziemlich krass und das Ganze vor
olympischen Jahr zum ersten Mal in der
40 Jahre langen WM-Geschichte kein
Podestplatz für den DLV und die Prognose
Richtung Paris sieht für den deutschen
Sport auch nicht gerade rosig aus so
Leichtathletik Präsident Jürgen die
Weltspitze ist in alt
die WM ohne Medaille hat viele Gründe ob
zu wenig Geld zu wenig gute Trainer oder
zu wenig Wettkampf hatte auf die
Schnelle zu beheben ist das kaum
dass ich jetzt von einem aufs nächste
Jahr jetzt nicht allzu extrem viel
ändert ich denke das sollte auch jedem
klar sein der realistisch an den Sport
herangeht und sich so ein bisschen in
der Szene auskennt unterdessen hat sich
Sebastian Koh in Budapest erneut gegen
das Vorhaben des IOC gestellt bei
Olympia in Paris im nächsten Jahr
russische und Wähler russische Athleten
zuzulassen
in der Türkei Portugal und Italien
ermöglichen müssen das ist für sie
unhaltbar daher werden sich meine
Ansichten soweit nicht ändern
die Ukraine Budapest einmal Gold und
einmal Silber
voll im Soll sind bisher die deutschen
Basketballer um Kapitän Dennis Schröder
zwei Spiele zwei Siege bei der WM in
Japan ein verheißungsvolle Auftakt der
zuversichtlich stimmt und auch bei der
Prominenz für gute Laune sorgt auch
Basketball-Legende Nowitzki begeistert
vom mitreißenden sie gestern gegen die
starken aus Italien schon vor dem
morgigen Spiel gegen Finnland steht der
Gruppensieg damit bereits
natürlich fokussiert bleiben und ähm
versuchen das dritte Spiel zu holen weil
das natürlich sehr wichtig ist denn
jedes einzelne Ergebnis wird in die
Gruppenphase mitgenommen der am Knöchel
verletzte NBA-Profi Franz Wagner steht
wohl wieder bereit die Tendenz geht aber
dahin ihn noch zu schonen
ja und die Volleyballerinnen sind bei
ihrer em-achtelfinale raus das musst du
noch sein Dankeschön Christin noch bis
morgen das sei noch gesagt noch bis
morgen Abend war der Deutsche
Wetterdienst vor ergiebigem Dauerregen
am Alpenrand auf was sie sich beim
Wetter sonst noch einstellen können
erfahren sie dann gleich von Katja
horneffer
Familienministerin Paulus im heute
journal Interview mit Christian Sievers
ab
21:45 Uhr ja das war es von uns für Sie
noch einen schönen Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend in den vergangenen 24
Stunden hat es sehr kräftig geregnet das
liegt an diesem Tief Erwin das hat viel
Regen mitgebracht auf die Alpen Südseite
in die Alpen und auch an den alten
Nordrand und es wird kräftig weiter
regnen bis morgen Abend gibt es noch
eine Unwetterwarnung des Deutschen
Wetterdienst
Dauerregen am Alpenrand auch sonst wird
es hier in Südosten Deutschlands weiter
regnen im Nordwesten ist es dagegen
trocken zum Teil klar dann bildet sich
auch mal Nebel die Temperaturen singen
auf 14 Grad hier in der Nordsee und auch
im Rhein-Main-Gebiet und bis 8 Grad am
Alpenrand und im Dauerregen bleibt es
morgen kühl an den Alpen da werden das
nur 12 Grad ähnlich wie im Vogtland
sonst werden immerhin bis zu 19 Grad auf
Rügen oder auch zwischen der
Nordseeküste und dem Niederrhein
erreicht und morgen schüttet es an den
alten Energie die ich weiter auch sonst
wird es hier sehr trüb und regnerisch
bleiben in der südostheft in Nordwesten
ist es etwas freundlicher da kommt
zwischen kräftigen Regenschauern auch
mal die Sonne zum Vorschein bei einem
heftigen Wind aus dem nördlichen bis
nordwestlichen Richtung die gute Aussage
für die nächsten Tage ist das wird von
Tag zu Tag sonniger und auch wieder
wärmer und den Dauerregen sind wir dann
los guten Abend